hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Battle Royale
season three has arrived and it brings a
host of visual improvements and vanity
items which it expects but it's what's
under the hood which is most impressive
including building options and how the
double-pump Mehta has been fixed oh and
if you haven't got the limited edition
ps4 skin on ps4 xbox or pc we'll show
you how to do that at the end of the
video so if you're ready let's check out
all the changes brought in in patch 3.0
point-o
like usual first up we'll start with the
visual differences our season 3 brings
in yet another battle pass and just in
case you haven't heard
epic have cancelled their plans to
eliminate V books to buy the pass so if
you're playing the PvE portion use your
hard-earned V bucks to buy the pass if
you new to the battle pass it's
essentially a grind mechanic unlocking
vanity items there's now 100 tiers to
the pass which includes four outfits one
of which is John freaking wick
there's three new pickaxes four new
emotes a couple of new gliders to grind
for 23 banners and 21 of those emoticons
I still don't use what about you but
here's where things change patch 3.0
point-o brings in new ways to stand out
from the crowd the first hour back
blinks which our rucksacks our backpacks
which can be switched out as you see fit
there's three in total to grind for on
top of this we have skydiving trails
which do exactly what you expect as you
jump out of the Battle of us you'll now
look like a member of a synchronized
skydiving team there's five of these to
unlock and to finish the list there's
also new loading screens to unlock eight
of them in total the challenge mechanics
have changed slightly weekly challenges
will now replace daily challenges as the
core mechanic to leveling up your battle
paths every week seven new challenges
become available and it's your job to
complete them in any order you see fit
but here's the kicker they stack you no
longer need to feel shackled to the game
don't be forced to play every day to
obtain the best rewards have a week off
if you're feeling burnt out and when you
return everything and more will be there
thank you so much epic games with that
out of the way here's where things get
interesting and potentially change the
game again the build mode has had a
little overhaul in the shape of turbo
building now instead of spamming the
button to build we can simply hold down
the trigger or button to paint walls and
ramps everywhere if you watch my
previous video about stutter lack this
will reduce that hugely and it gets even
better for the building element of the
game you can now build through objects
which previously stopped you trees gone
cars smashed hulking great rock
formations on your bike building has
once again become the car of the game so
don't be afraid to get out your massive
erections again didn't come out how I
expected but you know let's just move on
move on auto switch it gets even better
this will also automatically switch the
material you are building with once it
runs out so hopefully the days of
running off a ramp to your death because
you weren't paying attention to your
material count
if you prefer the old technique of
building there are switchable in the
settings menu if you are struggling with
the bright pink bunny blending into the
green grass then I have news for you you
may be color blind but don't worry jump
over into the accessibility settings and
sort that out so you're not at a
disadvantage all major color
deficiencies are now supported let's
quickly address the double-pump meta
it's gone you'll still see people
jumping around like headless chickens
but the way it's fixed should help us
all as the pump animation can no longer
be avoided by switching the weapon
quickly an easy fix
which should make the game more dynamic
again until another meta takes over
probably the SMG here's a massive one
for console gamers 60 frames per second
is now available on your console yes all
consoles even the base ps4 and the base
Xbox one that's damn impressive you'll
no longer need to click on the uncapped
frame rates in the settings to risk the
certain framerate and lag issues fingers
crossed if this works as intended oh
here's a really cool little improvement
once you win the game you are now able
to run around for 10 seconds after
victory so expect in mulch Geller as the
winner ridicules you and just before I
go I wanted to make sure you are all
aware of the limited edition ps4 skin
and glider and indeed they are available
on all platforms yes
that's Xbox and PC the item must be
unlocked on ps4 in the stop but once you
have that link your account on for
tonight comp or epic games comp and the
skin will be available wherever you play
right I need stop wasting my time here
and get back to unlocking John wick I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade it's been
a pleasure as always I'll see you in
tilted Telus I'll be the guy that dies
first